Dear Mr President
seeing a picture of you in today's
newspaper standing in front of a
barbecue grilling Quail reminded me that
I had never sent you the recipe of the
drop scones which I provided you at
Balmoral a letter from a queen to a
president where there are fewer I
generally put in less milk and flour but
use the other ingredients as stated we
remember with such pleasure your visit
to Balmoral yours sincerely Elizabeth r
the year was 1960 the president was
Eisenhower the queen was honoring a
culinary promise from his visit to
Balmoral a year earlier
six decades on the president's
granddaughter with an insight into one
relationship which fostered something
much deeper between two Nations the way
my grandparents chose to Mark her first
visit to the United States as Queen
um
really underscored the intimacy of of
this friendship
[Music]
through Manhattan's avenues that first
state visit was a spectacle indeed
images which nod to a different time
apply the ticker tape snowstorm he was
the wartime General who became president
and she the wartime princess who became
queen that was their bond
it's very moving because World War II
was one of those conflicts that really
bound people
and and at this level you're talking
about the Supreme Allied Commander the
five-star General eventually who accepts
the unconditional surrender of Nazi
Germany and the the royal family who had
really played an extraordinary role in
inspiring uh Great Britain and the world
during this really very dangerous time
the special relationship cited so often
Grew From Here and through so many
presidencies too
it was she not the politicians who
anchored the transatlantic friendship
and Susan Eisenhower remembers the start
of it
she stayed in the White House quarters
themselves my grandparents insisted that
she be treated like a guest to the
family my grandmother promptly dubbed at
the Queen's bedroom and brought it into
a special category really where only the
most important guests for the present
first lady would allow anyone to stay in
years later they would meet again it was
2007 the fifth and what would be the
Queen's last state visit to America I
found myself at the head table I was in
shock your majesty thank you for your
words tonight
and for the love and affection you have
shown the American people
over many years
do you know I'm going to miss this woman
very much it's so interesting I know all
of Americans feel that way but she was
really kind of a queen to all of us and
a real
um a real North Star for us
her role was always undefined but her
impact undeniable America's affection
and affinity for the queen and for
Britain remains palpable here Mark Stone
Sky News in the United States